ينضم الينا من معبر ارتس بيت حنون مراسل
الجزيره الياس كرام الياس اخر المعلومات
والتفاصيل
الميدانيه وما يردها الجيش الاسرائيلي من
معلومات واحاط بهذا الشان حتى
اللحظه نعم حسن هذه ربما اول مره نتمكن
فيها من الوصول الى معبر ايرز بيت حنون
شمال قطاع غزه منذ بدايه هذهه الحرب بعد
ان زال الجيش الاسرائيلي بعضا من حواجزه
العسكريه التي نصبها في هذه المنطقه التي
شهدت كثيرا من المواجهات والقتال ما بين
الجيش الاسرائيلي والمقاومه الفلسطينيه
التي كانت وصلت في الايام الاولى لهذه
الحرب الى هذه المنطقه تحديدا وسيطرت
عليها ودخلت الى نيتيف عسرا هذه البلده
القريبه من من ايرز وكذلك بعض البلدات
الاسرائيليه هناك حجم الدمار هنا كبير
للغايه لا يمكن اظهاره تحديدا في موقع
الموقع العسكري الذي تمت السيطره عليه من
كتائب القسام وهو موقع الارتباط
الاسرائيلي الموجود في هذه المنطقه لكن
واضح بان الجيش الاسرائيلي ما زال يحافظ
على وجود عسكري كبير في هذه ال المنطقه
وتحديدا عند معبر ايرز وكما نشاهد هذه
الاليات الثقيله المدرعات ناقلات الجند
وكذلك ال الجرافات العسكريه الثقيله ما ما
زالت موجوده هنا ونحن ما زلنا نسمع حسن
ايضا في الساعات الاخيره اشتباكات
بالرشاشات من العيار الثقيل في مناطقه
قريبه من السياج الامني اي في بيت حنون
وفي بيت لهيه كان واضحا بان
هذه المعارك ما زالت على حالها ما زالت
قائمه في مناطقه يفترض ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي كان يسيطر عليها منذ اليوم
الاول للعمليه البريه في ال 26 من اكتوبر
الماضي لكن من الواضح بان هنالك اصوات
لتفجيرات
وانفجارات مستمره في منطقه بيت حنون وفي
منطقه بيت لاهيه وبين الحين والاخر ايضا
هنالك سماع ل اطلاق الرشاشات من العيار
الثقيل من جانب الجيش الاسرائيلي نشير في
هذا السياق الى ان بيانات الجيش
الاسرائيلي تشير الى استمرار المعارك كذلك
في المناطق الوسطى لقطاع غزه تحديدا في
البريج وفي جحر الدين في المناطق الجنوبيه
ايضا لمدينه غزه حيث قال الجيش الاسرائيلي
قبل قليل في بيان له بانه استهدف منصات
لاطلاق الصواريخ كانت معده للاطلاق في
منطقه المغرا في المناطق الوسطى لقطاع غزه
وقام بتدميرها بعض الصور التي عممها الجيش
الاسرائيلي تظهر ايضا وجود انفجارات
متتاليه ناجمه عن استهداف هذه المنصات
للاطلاق الصاروخيه دا عن ذلك العم
المعلومات تشير الى ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
حسن كثف من غاراته ومن قصفه المدفعي على
المناطق الوسطى
لقطاع غزه فيما يقول بان ذروه العمليات
وزخمها متواصل في المناطق الجنوبيه للقطاع
تحديدا في منطقه خانيونس حيث يواصل قتاله
الشرس هناك كما ي بما انك في في في هذه
المنطقه معبر ارتز شمال قطاع غزه وهذه اول
مره تدخل الى هذه المنطقه
الياس لو يعني اعطيتنا مزيدا من التفاصيل
عن طبيعه هذه المنطقه ما الذي يجري حولك
وقد كنا شاهدنا تعزيزات اسرائيليه موجوده
هناك و ماذا كان دور هذا المعبر
سابقا حسن هذا المعبر كان احد اهم المعابر
لدخول وخروج الفلسطينيين من قطاع غزه
ودخول الفلسطينيين ايضا من مناطق الضفه
الغربيه الى داخل القطاع وكذلك المؤسسات
الرسميه والدوليه التي كانت تدخل الى
منطقه القطاع هذا المعبر مغلق بطبيعه
الحال منذ يوم السابع من اكتوبر وكان ايضا
معبرا ومنفذا هاما لدخول العمال
الفلسطينيين الى داخل اسرائيل للعمل لكن
ال منذ السابع من اكتوبر اغلق هذا المعب
بالكامل وكان قد تعرض ايضا للقصف من جانب
قوات الجيش الاسرائيلي في اليوم الاول
للحرب حيث كانت كتائب القسام قد سيطرت
عليه في هجومها الكبير في السابع من من
اكتوبر هذا هذا المعبر حسن شهد ايضا في
الايام ال الاولى للحرب اشتباكات عنيفه ما
بين الجيش الاسرائيلي وما بين المسلحين
الفلسطينيين ما بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه
بعض عناصر المقاومه وصلوا الى هذه المنطقه
الى منطقه السياج الامني واشتبكوا مع قوات
الجيش الاسرائيلي من منطقه صفر الجيش
الاسرائيلي مازال يحافظ كما هو ملاحظ في
الصوره على وجود عسكري كبير في هذه
المنطقه ونحن قريبون ايضا من منطقه موقع
الارتباط او قياده الارتباط الاسرائيليه
مع قطاع غزه هذه القياده التي تعرضت لهجوم
كبير في السابع من اكتوبر تمكنا من الوصول
اليها لكن طبعا منعنا من التصوير هناك كان
واضحا بان حجم الدمار كبير جدا في داخل
هذه القياده العسكريه وهذا الدمار كان
ناجما عن الهجوم في السابع من اكتوبر
الماضي الجيش الاسرائيلي ما زال يحافظ على
وجود عسكري كما اشرت وواضح بان الاشتباكات
العسكريه ما زالت على حالها ما زالت على
اشدها في هذه المناطق القريبه من السياج
الامني هذه المنطقه تتعرض ايضا لقصف
صاروخي بين الحين والاخر من جانب المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وقصف ايضا بقذائف الهاون على
اعتبار انها منطقه قريبه من السياج الامني
لذلك تستهدف فيها القوات الاسرائيليه ليس
فقط بالصواريخ
القصيره المدى انما ايضا بقذائف الهاون
المنطقه هذه كما قال الجيش الاسرائيلي
وكما قالت الحكومه الاسرائيليه ستبقى
مغلقه على اعتبار ان اسرائيل تريد كما
تقول فك الارتباط مع الفلسطينيين وتتوقع
ان يبقى هذا المعبر مغلقا لفتره طويله فقط
للاشاره
الياس خلفك من بعد هذا الهنغار يفترض ان
تكون مدينه او بلده بيت
حانون بالفعل بالفعل حسن نحن قريبون جدا
نحن على مسافه صفر تقريبا من السياج
الامني وبيت حنون من خلفنا وكذلك منطقه
بيت لاهيه التي ما زالت كما قلت حتى هذه
الساعه تشهد اعمالا قتاليه نحن نسمع
بطبيعه الحال اشتباكات بالرشاشات الثقيله
وكذلك تفجيرات يبدو انها ناجمه عن عمليات
التمشيط التي ما زالت مستمره من جانب
الجيش الاسرائيلي الجيش الاسرائيلي لم
يغادر هذه المنطقه وهو يعمل على تفجير
الانفاق الهجوميه التي يقول بانها موجوده
في اكثر من موقع وفي اكثر من مكان في بيت
لاهيه وفي بيت حنون وعم وعمليه التمشيط
مستمره لذلك بعض التفجيرات التي نسمعها هي
ناجمه عن عمليات التمشيط التي يقوم بها
الجيش الاسرائيلي هناك شكرا لك الياس كرام
من معبر ارت بيت حنون